I think it reminds us straight away of
all of the fraud that the current prime
minister presided over when he was
Chancellor near the 12 billion pounds in
dodgy contract in fraud and covid fraud
and all the dodgy contracts and so on
and I think what this reminds us of is
that when Richie soon now became prime
minister he stood on the steps of
Downing Street talking about I think
professionalism accountability integrity
and yet we see more stories of people in
the conservative party involved in the
stories um like this I think it really
damages trust in politics and it should
be a wake-up culture if she soon had to
get on top of this but is it reasonable
to criticize
um Michael Gove because you know all he
did was he was approached we were right
in the middle of the pandemic and he
just passed on the email well I think we
need to find out what happened um but I
think that there is a whole set of
questions around covid fraud and waste
and which hang around the Prime Minister
and really the Buck has to stop with him
so he used to get on top of this and we
need to know what happened okay
um what do you make of suggestions from
the leveling up and housing secretary
this morning that actually
um the organization in Rochdale and
others as well will have money removed
from them until they get their act
together
I think it's right to take firm action
against social housing providers against
social landlords who are not looking
after their tenants and the what
happened in Rochdale was heartbreaking
shocking
um it should be a wake-up call to
government to do something about making
sure that social housing landlords
aren't allowed to get away with this so
I think that's right I think that what I
would add to it
um is that there's another problem in
housing alongside what's happening in
the social sector which is what's
happening in the private rented sector
as well where there's also very bad
conditions in a lot of cases um and one
of the real issues with the private
rented sector is that because the
regulation is so weak and tenants can't
complain because if you complain in the
private rented sector you can get
evicted and so actually there's a whole
bit of work that needs to be done a
really urgent and long overdue piece of
work that needs to be done about
strengthening protections of private
tenants as well yeah but I want to take
you back to the point that the
government wants to take money off these
social housing organizations how is that
going to help them get better if they've
got less money to do it with
so my understanding of the announcement
is this relates to the investment in you
in new build and I suppose there's a
good argument which is that if you can't
look after your current properties and
make sure your current tenants are well
served by a landlord should you really
be building new homes yes so that you
can get them out of those bad quality
accommodation and put them into a new
one well there's no excuse for bad
landlords and I think although social
landlords play a really crucial role in
terms of building new social housing
that can't be an excuse to let them get
away with treating tenants taking money
off them how does that help well that's
money for new Builders as I understand
as I said by building new properties
then you can get them out of the stuff
that isn't fit for purpose I think it's
really important to make sure that the
current homes that the social landlords
own manage are decent quality I think
saying that if we can build new homes we
can just leave the old homes in the
state they are is not a tenable
situation you know we have we have to
build new Council housing new social
housing but we absolutely have to make
sure that the current social housing we
have in the country is up to standard
and we saw the absolutely devastating
impact when that is not the case do you
support the government's um energy
saving campaign that they are saying
that we need to save 15 of energy not
necessarily because of the cost also
because of the cost but but you know we
don't know where we're getting our
energy from
what I think is absolutely right to make
sure that we're not wasting energy
particularly at the moment what do you
do to save energy at home what do I do
to save energy well we make sure we we
keep our heating on as little as
possible it's been quite late in the
year that we first turn our heating on
um I actually we just had a discussion
at home the other day about let's not
put the heating on today let's make sure
we're putting jumpers on first because I
think it's in all of our minds about
making sure that we don't overspend and
you know I'm in a position where I don't
have to worry about paying my energy
bills but I know that people across the
country are worried about paying their
energy bills and that's why we need to
make sure we have that supporting place
for people through the months ahead but
also in the long run you know we're very
focused rightly so on getting people
through the winter and the months ahead
but actually what the government should
be doing at the same time is investing
in that insulation of properties
investing in new renewable homegrown
energy sources to make sure that we can
bring bills down and have more stable
energy supplies in the future what
temperature do you have your heating on
at home I think it's about 20 20 years
quite high that isn't it it's a bit hard
to look at that I'll look at that one
again I think I'm apparently 17 is what
17. yeah my goodness me okay well I've
got another sweater on I think have you
been watching the football
um I must admit I haven't this week
because I think the the first game on on
Monday was that uh during a meeting we
had in the shadow treasury team so I
wasn't watching that
um although I did notice uh some of my
staff members had a little window open
on this uh good for them how do you feel
about
um the glazers potentially selling
Manchester United and it could of course
go to a Saudi buyer
um well from what I picked up on on what
menu fans have been saying some of them
are quite Keen for this to happen
um in terms of the sale I mean I think
you know there's lots of different
um
if it was sold to societies well there's
lots of different ownerships involved in
in football and different clubs I think
there's a bigger picture here about the
social responsibility that's connected
with football and we've seen that you
know really starkly in terms of what's
happening in Qatar
um you know the role of the England fan
England players uh England fans LGBT
plus England fans being anxious perhaps
about going uh to Qatar I think actually
you know as a gay man myself
um when I heard foreign secretary say
what's the effect of act less gay if
you're going out to watch football I was
pretty appalled by that to be honest
because I thought it should be his job
to make sure that LGBT plus England and
Wales fans can go out there and enjoy
the game